In the previous unit, we have introduced the notion of NP completeness
and seen that a myriad of practically relevant problem is NP complete.
So, we think there is no polynomial time algorithm for these problems.
Now, the question last time we left off was what does this mean
for Alice, Bob, and Carol--the three computer scientists we were following?
Should they just give up?
Should they ask for a new problem?
And I think that is something they might do,
arguing that the problems are NP-complete,
but actually they could do much better,
using some of the techniques that you are about to learn in this unit and the following units.
Because what we will now be investigating is techniques to actually solve problems
despite their NP-completeness.
Now, this will not always work,
but it will be much better than just giving up,
because there are so many NP-complete problems out there
that are just too practically relevant to leave them alone.